you could kick off the world cup
tomorrow on this turf the stadium air
conditioning in here works perfectly but
the questions about how these gleaming
stadiums have been built and how many
migrant lives have been lost will not
stop how do you reassure people that the
workers have been treated well well we
have a worker welfare a colleague a lot
of people working to support this kind
of a proper action
the controversies that started when
qatar won the tournament back in 2010
are still dividing fifa members who met
in doha on the eve of the draw
there is no room for employers who do
not secure the freedom and safety of
world cup workers
no room for hosts that cannot legally
guarantee the safety and respect of
lgbtq plus people coming to this theater
of dreams
the more that human rights or
inclusiveness are mentioned the more
defensive the hosts here are becoming
one qatari executive said that the head
of the norwegian fa should have gone to
him first to educate herself better the
england manager gareth southgate is just
one of several coaches who acknowledge
that qatar's laws that criminalize
homosexuality could deter lgbt plus fans
the organizers have said repeatedly
everyone is welcome it's kind of an
issue when you just base an opinion that
you're very vocal about on things that
you have read
somebody with a lot of influence such as
southgate somebody with
a big audience that listens to what he
says he's got to pick his words very
carefully
fifa argue that it's precisely because
the world cup is coming here that
workers rights and contracts have
dramatically improved over the past
decade and you know when i hear some of
the comments
by some people who say well
world cup shouldn't go there because the
arab world and
they have no tradition
who says it the ball doesn't belong to
anyone
the ball belongs to everyone
england are among the favorites scotland
or wales could still make it if they do
they'll be joining fifa's football
family gathering a family that really
does have issues
tom parmenter sky news qatar